I brought you here today for one reason
and one reason only to do something
extraordinary to do something that was
out of your comfort zone and into a
completely different league Kai the dish
he looked at it it was like it came out
of a a Gucci handbag it was all precise
and just beautifully done the beef
phenomenal love the mayonnaise
intelligent smart and had that kind of
Wow
criticizing the dish
I would have took the pumpkin for
another two minutes it's little bit
crunchy inside
you knew the Wagyu absolutely beautiful
because you you played To Your Strengths
what would I change it was simple today
I didn't think you'd go simple I thought
you'd go a little bit more a little bit
more daring
but this competition is not going to be
won or lost on one dish alone I'm
looking for the best restaurant great
food great service great atmosphere
friendly approach and something that you
want to go back to that restaurant for
that phenomenal experience
the restaurant that's going through the
semi-final based on everything
I've seen taste it and being part of is
Junior
continue those fireworks yeah you
deserve to be out there love the
fireworks love it love it love it
good job you're an amazing restaurant
yet look after
cause I'm absolutely gutted there we're
not getting through the answer wasn't
the answer we would have liked to hear
but we have to move on and keep going
with what we do every single day
well done really well done I said you
had a lot of weigh on your shoulders
today you pulled it off
I was just based on that dishes based on
the whole experience really well done
she'd be incredibly proud yeah a bloody
good job get really well done I think
okay well done well them all done I'm
very happy it feels amazing
I can't wait to want to help me more
that's just good I'll believe
we're really powerful enough to say yeah
I'm always yeah you know you're into a
good job being a good teacher
yeah it's a good job
I thought maybe good
through a jungle
don't offend really sorry to say goodbye
to Kai and that chefs a bit of a mad
genius however you and you great
restaurant
what an amazing family and their their
consistent and United